hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in book three of his work on anger
Seneca is going to begin an important
discussion about not taking on too much
if we want to avoid getting angry and
he's going to begin by quoting something
from a much earlier philosopher who we
don't have much by unfortunately
Democritus who is supposed to always be
quite happy in his life and he calls
this Democritus a salutary teaching that
is teach teaching for health to help us
out mental health in this case and he
says that it shows that the path to
tranquility and it's actually the term
tranquilitas there lies in undertaking
few activities and none beyond our
strength in both private and public
affairs and he's going to use that
distinction several times throughout
this discussion Private Affairs things
that have to do just with ourselves and
our friends and our house our commercial
dealings perhaps and then public affairs
things that have to do with the wider
society in which we participate and you
could stop for a second there and think
about you know the world of social media
and the internet as perhaps being
something quite public but also for many
people quite private as well
and so you know the issue here is not to
take on too much we don't want to uh
overwhelm or overburden ourselves right
so a few activities none beyond our
strength or capacities view race and in
Latin what it is that we can actually
accomplish and so he goes on and he says
um when a person is bustling this way
and they have to handle many
transactions the day never passes so
felicitously or happily right that
someone or something doesn't cause an
offense that will Prime the mind for
anger so you know if you take on a lot
of different things one of those is
going to screw up you can fill up your
schedule maybe with a day planner or
something with 10 different activities
well you might be better off with five
or three he goes on and he's got got
some examples just as we're hurrying
through the city's crowded spaces it's
inevitable we're going to bump into many
people tripping here getting stuck there
or being splashed in some other place
and so we can draw a more General
conclusion from this analogy in leading
a life that is scattered and undirected
we run into many obstacles and many
causes for complaints this one has
deceived our hope that one has delayed
its fulfillment another one is put it to
an end our projects have not progressed
smoothly in accordance with our plans
you know we're relying on other people
doing what they say they're going to do
or the weather or timetables or whatever
else cooperating with their ideas so if
we take on too much we are really
creating a lot of occasions for anger
the more things that we take on perhaps
the more opportunities we have for
getting angry and he goes on and he will
say
the person whose plans has set back has
no patience patience for what for people
other human beings who choose to do
things or for things all the other
matters could be animals could be plants
could be you know whether the Bus shows
up on time or whether the Bus Blows past
you as you're waiting for it could be
the weather you walk out and you didn't
bring an umbrella and it starts raining
on you anything that you like could be
your computer going down could be the
internet not working could be and we
could go on and on and on so they're not
going to have patience when their plans
are set back with any of those things
and they're going to be like it says
become angry for the most trivial
reasons now at a person now at a
transaction now at a place now at
Fortune luck chance Randomness now even
at himself
so if you want to have your mind as he
says not in turmoil
um you know for the mind to be quiet it
must not be in turmoil or wearied by
activities that are on the one hand
numerous right or Beyond us so we've got
two different dimensions here we've got
taking on too many different things
which Each of which might be within our
capacities but put together as a whole
aren't or sometimes we take on things
that just by themselves are too much for
us we often do this by the way when
we're in the process of fixing our lives
you know if we want to think about
philosophy as a way of life and stoicism
is one of those people learn about this
they read some Seneca and they're like
I'm gonna totally change my life I'll
never be angry again well that's not
going to happen it's going to take you
years and years of work to change the
habits and character that and
assumptions and responses that you've
built up over time it's not quite so
simple as that or people will you know
have a financial setback I will never be
poorer again well that's not totally up
to you now is it so sometimes we take on
a bit too much right he says you uh you
want you don't want to be weird by
activities that are too numerous or
substantial seeking ends beyond our
means that's kind of a nice phrase there
for just taking on too much for what
we're capable of and he goes on and says
it's easier to shoulder light burdens
and transport them this way and that
without a slip but we have a hard time
supporting burdens that others Place on
US overwhelmed we shrug them off at the
first opportunity even while we stand
under the bundle we totter because we're
unequal to the weight so a lot of
interesting physical metaphors there in
the next chapter he goes on and he talks
about once again Civic and domestic
affairs so the public and the private
and he tells us that um
you know we need to worry about taking
on projects that are just too much for
us these will lead us off course like he
says those that are massive and Beyond
the agents Powers don't yield rattling
and once undertaken they oppress HIM
lead him off course just when success
seems to be in his grab they bring him
and the whole Enterprise down and this
is a big problem
so even if you do manage to succeed for
a while with some massive undertaking
that is going to be you know
revolutionary Innovative changing
everything you notice this hyperbolic
language that people tend to use
it's not going to work because you're
not going to get all the way to the end
and then you're likely to get
overwhelmed and as a response to feel
angry
and so he's got this great line and
distinction here he says it frequently
happens that a man who doesn't undertake
easy things
but wants the things he's undertaken to
be easy has his intentions foiled so
there's a couple things to say about
that one is that he's actually using the
language of will or the faculty that
does the choosing right so the person
who wants things easy who Wills them
easy volt right and he's going to have
his intentions foiled erata sit as
voluntas voluntas is the will again
right erata frustrated angered right his
will itself is going to get angry it's
going to go off course it's not going to
do what it ought to do why because
he doesn't take on easy things but takes
on hard things and tells himself that
these are going to be somehow easy and
so many people do this in so many
different things I'm going to learn how
to do French cooking right now French
cooking is complicated there's a lot
going on there you need certain
ingredients you need to master several
important techniques you got to actually
stand at the stove and do things you
know while you might be doing other
things you can't just sit there and
listen to a podcast while you're
supposed to be looking at the recipe
when you're first starting out right and
so if you take on something and you want
it to be easy but it's not easy well
you're setting yourself up for some
anger because you're setting yourself up
for failure
and so he tells us whenever you're going
to attempt something what you need to do
is gauge or literally measure matere way
out yourself and the undertaking and
your preparation for it all at once and
it's interesting because the the words
that are being used here
you're supposed to check your own
Readiness your own capacity and the
things you're working with so it's not
just you yourself it's also I mean if
you're gonna do some cooking did you
actually buy the ingredients do you know
what the recipe that you're following is
do you understand some of the basic
principles and do you have the
techniques that you need we could go on
and on and on from there right so you
have to actually before you undertake
something think about whether you at
this point in time have the capacities
for it and this can affect every area of
life oh I'm going to have a kid and it's
going to be so wonderful well anybody
who's been a parent knows that there are
Joys to Parenthood and many many
frustrations and difficulties as well
and that's if you actually have a kid
where things are going fairly well with
them what if you have a kid and they
have all sorts of problems then you know
your life might be much more difficult
than you you originally anticipated
so he goes on and he says regret for a
task left uncomplete will make you
irritable and then he says here uh it
makes a difference whether one's nature
is Ardent and cold and abject or humilus
uh sort of
downtrodden right and he tells us that
um failure is going to elicit anger in a
noble generosis person depression or
sadness tristia in one who is limp and
super Supine and so he tells us that we
shouldn't attempt conamore we shouldn't
uh strive for anything we would be
surprised to succeed in we should keep
ourselves within a certain kind of
measure right
it's it's fine if we're mildly surprised
in in this case if we Marvel at
something everything coming together
well but we shouldn't be really
surprised we shouldn't say wow I had no
idea I'd actually succeed because what
we're doing there is we're saying I was
so stupid as to take on a task I was
pretty sure I wouldn't succeed in and
then we can get quite quite upset with
it so he tells us that our undertakings
are oxions the things that we're doing
should be neither too small small nor
Reckless odacas nor Wicked in probi
right so there's kind of a nice measure
again here we don't want to take on
things that are
too easy right we want life to have some
involvement some spice you could say but
we also don't want to go beyond what we
can do and we also don't want to be
engaging in bad actions just to like you
know make a splash or something like
that he also says something else really
interesting here
typically stoics are
rather dismissive of hope they view it
as an emotion that's not particularly
good here Seneca actually talks about it
hopes space
should stay close to home in vikinum
right in the neighborhood so it's okay
to Hope but your hopes need to be
rational they need to not go way the
hell out there right so you know what
would this rule out you know buying a
lottery ticket and hoping that you're
going to win the big Powerball prize
here in the United States Powerball is a
you know the millions and millions of
dollars right your odds of actually
winning anything pretty low your odds of
winning that big prize super super low
astronomically low so don't let your
hopes go too far out you're going to go
fishing and you're fishing in a place
that has mostly you know bluegill and
and other panfish you probably probably
shouldn't hope that you're going to
catch a muskie I mean Muskie fishing is
a whole specialization that takes hours
and hours and hours even just to get a
strike panfish that's easy right if you
hope that you're going to catch you know
a nice bunch of bluegill that might
happen might not happen but to hope that
you're going to catch some Giant game
fish that's actually long enough for you
to keep
that's pretty low so keep your hopes uh
within the neighborhood all of this is
great advice from Seneca once again
bringing in you know another earlier
philosopher with this Insight that if we
want to avoid being angry let's not take
on so much and definitely not take on
things that were not equal to and will
avoid the frustrations and regrets and
impatience that lead us into losing our
temper so easily